this virus is making its way to Capitol
Hill now two members of Congress a
testing positive Florida Republican
Mario diaz-balart has tested positive
for the corona virus as well as Utah
Democrat Ben McAdams here is the letter
sent by the Capitol attending a
physician on that senator it reads the
office of attending physicians
identified the offices and locations
that were found to be at risk and they
have been treated by the architect of
the Capitol other instances where the
affected members may have briefly come
into contact with other colleagues on
the House floor would be considered to
be low risk exposures and no additional
measures are required other than for
them to report any illness should they
become ill what is your response to
those two members of Congress now
testing positive and where this all goes
next for you and your colleagues well
Sandra this raises a critical issue
which is after 9/11 lots of work was
done here to provide for Congress to
meet and vote somewhere other than the
Capitol in the event there were a
successful attack on our Capitol but
they never came to agreement on
emergency procedures that would allow
the Senate or the house to vote remotely
that's now being actively debated I've
reached out to the affected members of
Congress and conveyed my concerns to
them and their staff but you know
frankly the Capitol is almost empty
right now almost all of my staff is
working remotely the rest of the
Delaware congressional delegation staff
is working remotely we are practicing
social distancing and many are
sheltering in place and teleworking but
frankly we don't have a provision that
allows us to take up and pass some of
these significant bills that provide
support for families and workers and
communities we also need to pass Indre a
bill that would allow for vote-by-mail
i've introduced one yesterday it's being
led by Senator Wyden in the middle of
the Civil War in the middle of the
Second World War we were able to carry
out elections and get ballots to our
troops in the field and allow them to
still vote we just saw the Ohio primary
delayed abruptly we need to make sure
we're making provisions and providing
resources so there are elections at the
state and federal level aren't
interrupted by this pandemic